what's going on guys
sin city a dame to kill for it's hitting
theaters and that got me thinking about
graphic novels that have been turned
into major motion pictures today
things are gonna get graphic and we have
a cool panel to get graphic with first
he is an actor and a comedian he's a
good friend of the show Mike Carlson
thank you he'll good to be here he is an
actor and a director of NTSF SD SUV on
Adult Swim and the upcoming hotwives of
orlando alex ferny hello yeah so guys
first off right off the bat I want to
get something straight
what's a graphic novel I think
traditionally is things that were
intended to be of a longer format it's
also a phrase used by people that are
embarrassed to read comic have to make
it feel like it's actually like oh well
it's a graphic novel it's not comic book
you know what dialed those pretentious
idiots are for the birds I agree with
you hell yeah if that's you click a wet
note to keep watching but walk away
believe it run it yeah walk away believe
it running so uh is this a graphic novel
I think so in it because uh it tells a
contained story everyone knows that
exact copy of Watchmen yes the way
Watchmen looks and I think to most
people that's the way it's perceived not
individual issues do you guys have any
favorite film adaptations of graphic
novels I'm going to say that first Sin
City because I do like that it was a
really interesting experiment in the
sense that they were really just going
for like we're gonna take the panels
from the comic so we're gonna recreate
it as perfectly as possible they really
did it it's a beautiful movie to look at
and it's a pretty fun movie as well and
I think Watchmen tried to do the same
thing I think you're right I think
Watchmen gave it a shot but the whole
point of Watchmen is playing with the
form of comics of graphic novels and
when they just tried to translate bad
over a lot of it didn't work what my
favorites is a Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world it goes the other way really
successfully where it grabs what I loved
about the graphic novels and then
changes things that need to be changed
because it's a different medium it's
like you should take the spirit of the
thing you're working with and then adapt
it to the medium and that's what Scott
Pilgrim did so well I was looking up the
highest grossing comic book and graphic
novel adaptation
RIPD made more than Scott Pilgrim that's
why we can't have nice things
ghosts men and black did better so we're
talking about some graphic novel film
adaptations that we like that we respect
are there any that came out were you
like oh boy
no they blew it I'll throw one out there
yeah League of Extraordinary general
yeah it was like the filmmakers like
this is a cool story let's just do it
just get it out there III also say
another one that just went like I didn't
like the book either just wanted it just
felt to me like like a 13 year old boy
stop masturbating just long enough to
write like his fever dream of violence
and like yeah there you go and then
you'll a went back to what that seems
like so many things yeah
and that was like so many things are
inspired that I think the book ending
with the middle finger to the audience
and then like the movie doing the same
sort of thing like like oh my god okay
we've talked about a couple of these
films already I'd like to run down the
list of the highest-grossing graphic
novel film adaptations at the box office
and we'll just throw out some thoughts
on them okay 300 it's pretty but like 15
minutes in you go like oh this is the
whole movie this is what its gonna be
like pretty apt Acula though no wanted
we talked about that a little bit a
little bit of a disappointment yeah
Watchmen I think at this point its
watchman is underrated I think it was
also an attempt to make something that
is I think fairly unfilmable in the same
way there's like never been a great
great gatsby movie I think Watchmen is
going to stand as that as being like
yeah take your shot at it but what was
created is what it was intended to be uh
ii 300 rise of an empire Road to
Perdition I was kind of soso on I
thought it dragged a little bit and then
I don't like seeing Tom Hanks ISM
murderer I want I want Tom Hanks like if
humming system murder someone I want him
to be like okay it's my last resort I'm
a desperate I'm acting my kids yes um
get off my boat the sort of thing right
he's always saying that yeah my vote
every if you go back and watch every Tom
Hanks movie at one point just get off my
boat Cowboys and Aliens Harrison Ford as
the cowboy I had an issue with very
strong cruise control going on hopefully
flips the switch or star horse Oh
brain please help please read no such
I've never seen either yeah me neither
um okay I might be in the minority on
this one two guns I out do you guys see
mm I think you guns I saw two guns
I liked it that's it until it was Denzel
and Mark Wahlberg I thought it was just
you know a fun shoot-'em-up it was like
a lesser Lethal Weapon movie Yeah right
yeah Sin City which we can all agree was
pretty well done why is this new one
like nine years later or whatever it is
it seems like there's a little bit oh
it's kind of a throwback thing oh it's
kind of a cute nostalgic thing rather be
like Oh strike while the iron's hot
let's get this franchise up and rolling
it feels almost like some studio was
like gosh we got this much money left
we're gonna burn it otherwise we won't
get it next year uh do another one of
these yeah there are three more
installments of the Sin City graphic
novels that we haven't found yet maybe
they're just waiting for Mickey Rourke
I mean agree or disagree Mickey Rourke's
real face weirder than his big Sin City
face much weirder much weird cuz the big
weird face you're gonna like that's a
weird face that his normal fits you
going like oh I don't wanna bring it up
oh yeah and then Oh finally we haven't I
can't believe we haven't talked about
this yet V for Vendetta well what do you
guys think about V for Vendetta it's
fine yeah I think it's one of the most
successful more adaptations on film
mm-hmm but I don't think I've watched
you since it came out there are a couple
of adaptations that we haven't talked
about yet I really liked Ghost World
I thought that well sure yeah yeah yeah
kick-ass we haven't talked about him um
that was really well done I feel like
that opened the door to a lot of
different takes on superheroes I don't
know if kick-ass to shut that door yeah
but like it was there is sort of like an
interesting counterpoint to like what
the huge budget superhero movies are are
there any graphic novels that haven't
been made into films that you that you'd
like to see I would say it's coming out
in issues betting is intended to be read
as one story it would be velvet velvet
is about sort of this aging female
ex-spy who gets kind of like yanked back
into this world through betrayal and
it's just been really fun and like just
the what if James Bond was you know the
50 year old woman who retired I'd also
like to see
we three oh yeah because they're
supposedly Grant Morrison has written a
script and the guy from Kung Fu Panda
wants to make it but no one wants to
finance a weird movie where animals are
fighting each other and humans yeah that
needs to get made yeah
so guys I'll see you at the movies this
weekend for our Sin City dame to kill
for date I'm gonna line up Thursday at
midnight okay that does make a new chore
okay you Milan Dubai the tickets I'll
buy the popcorn Friday morning at 9:00
a.m.
Mike Carlson Alex Bernie thanks for
coming by and talking about graphic
novels that were turned into movies
pleasure thank you he'll ah so what's
your favorite movie adaptation of a
graphic novel tell us in the comments
below we want to know this episode is
brought to you by Best Buy where you can
experience the best in Ultra HD TVs
check out the sweepstakes link in the
description below and enter for a chance
to win an amazing Ultra HD TV from
screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick thank you
for watching hit me up on Twitter bye
bye shredder probably need to block hey
that mutagen is alien like that fine no
one cares about that from what alien
planet or what's dimension right let's
bring crane into the movie there's been
five movies why ever we see Frank